[Música]
vem com meu eu quero te mostrar um
caminho pra saúde encontrar
no canal do T além do tra Universo de
saúde natural remédios naturais dicas
incríveis cuide de você de forma simples
visível vem nessa compartilhar e espalha
a
notícia a saúde das pessoas merece
atenção e
[Música]
delícia compartilhe os vídeos faça o bem
a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do T além do TR
desenvolv Viva Saúde natural vamos
juntos se
[Música]
desenvolv compartilha os vídeos faço bem
a vida de alguém pode mudar também no
canal do d além do TR se
envolva Viva Saúde
natural vamos juntos se
[Música]
desenvolv Olá meus amigos minhas amigas
para mais uma live eu tava brincando com
o aplicativo que gera música por
eu acho que ele fez um trabalho até bem
razoável né Essa vinhetinha aí que eu
criei eu vou acho que eu vou aproveitar
para colocar nos vídeos né Eu queria a
opinião de vocês quer dizer quem tiver
assistindo né agora ao vivo Deixa eu ver
quem tá
[Música]
assistindo o Carlos ketman está
assistindo né a Marta perz Boa noite PR
os dois conseguiram escutar aí o a
vinhetinha que que vocês acharam me deem
aí
uma posição aí que que vocês acharam da
vinheta por coisa ponho ela de
novo bem vamos falar aqui de um artigo
muito interessante sobre os alisantes de
cabelo o impacto que podem ter à saúde
Você já pensou que o seu creme alizante
né no caso das mulheres que usam né de
cabelo poderia estar fazendo mal à sua
saúde não estão apenas prejudicando os
fios em si deixando eles fracos Mas
podem causar risco à saúde então
bem-vindo a esse assunto Nós vamos
mergulhar numa descoberta surpreendente
que vem da França os pesquisadores
Descobriram que o uso de produtos para
alisamento de cabelo contendo o ácido
glioxílico
ácido glioxílico não é o formol né que
se
utilizava antigamente está associado a
risco para a insuficiência renal
aguda isso mesmo você não viu errado né
estamos falando sobre a possibilidade
desses produtos causarem danos aos rins
devido ao acúmulo de cristais de Oxalato
de cálcio então Nesse artigo vamos
aprofundar sobre essa descoberta
entender como é que essa reação química
acontece e Que produtos são
esses vamos revelar um risco oculto que
muitos
usuários estão enfrentando sem nem mesmo
se darem conta então boa noite Carlos
Marta
a Mir
Oliveira eu acho que a Marta ouviu
a a vinhetinha né quem não ouviu a
vinhetinha no final do vídeo eu vou
colocar de novo tá para vocês escutarem
para vocês me darem opinião o que que
vocês acharam da vinheta aí que eu gerei
com música por Inteligência Artificial
tá cada vez ficando mais sofisticado viu
e ficou muito convincente no meu ponto
de
vista bem a primeira sessão que nós
vamos discutir desse artigo
eh a saúde dos nossos rins é um assunto
de extrema importância todos vocês sabem
esses dois órgãos vitais desempenham
funções críticas cruciais para filtrar o
sangue manutenção do equilíbrio do nosso
corpo então equipe francesa de
pesquisadores liderada pelo Dr Emanuel L
let
tavernier nos revela uma conexão
altamente alarmante que temre os
produtos de alisamento capilar que
contém um produto chamado ácido glix
sílico e o risco de ter problema de
função renal insuficiência renal aguda
os zins não funcionarem
direito então em animais após a
aplicação tópica de um produto de
alisamento contendo esse ácido
glioxílico foi observada uma infensa
renal aguda grave dentro de 24 horas
então devem ter usado uma dose bem alta
né que geralmente ess estudos em animais
eles usam doses bem cavalares então
fizeram biópsia nos zins dos Camundongos
e mostrou a presença de cristais salato
de cálcio né que é o principal
constituinte das
Pedras em todos os túbulos
renais isso é significativo pois sugere
que a via de absorção transcutânea do
produto pela pele né pode acarretar
riscos substantivos da Saúde renal que
leva a levantar hipótese sobre a
segurança dos produtos capilares que as
mulheres especialmente as mulheres
homens também usa né mas especialmente
as mulheres usam para alisar os
cabelos então então o os autores relatam
o caso Clínico de uma jovem de 26 anos
que apresentou vários episódios de danos
renais Agudos após visitas a um salão de
beleza onde fez alisamento capilar com
um produto contendo ácido glioxílico
Então esse ácido glioxílico foi o
substituto ao form adid ao famoso formol
Então
formaldeído ele era historicamente
utilizado em muitos alisantes de cabelo
ele é conhecido por ser irritante e
potencialmente cancerígeno levando a sua
substituição por outros compostos que
eram considerados mais seguros um desses
compostos é o ácido glioxílico que
embora seja elogiado por suas qualidades
e alizamento está se revelando agora
tóxico aos rins d a utilização do ácido
glioxílico como ingrediente em produtos
cosméticos principalmente como
alternativa ao formaldeído oferece um
risco potencial de dano aos í de
nefrotoxicidade Então os pesquisadores
franceses sugerem que baseado nas
evidências atuais produtos com esse
composto devem ser evitados e retirados
do mercado se possível emissões de
alerta já foram feitas a agência
reguladora
francesa então é importante que fazer
uma diferenciação entre esse produto
ácido glioxílico e o ácido glicólico né
para esclarecer a suspeita sobre a
toxicidade do ácido glicólico que é
outro ácido frequentemente encontrado em
produtos cosméticos os pesquisadores
realizaram o segundo estudo em animais
que ofereceu resultados reveladores e
importantes paraa comunidade científica
e consumidores Então esse outro que
terão bem parecido o ácido glicólico
glicólico ao contrário do glico xíc não
induziu a formação de cristais de
Oxalato nos rins dos Camundongos nem nem
mesmo a falência renal
os resultados desse estudo são cruciais
pois afastam a preocupação com o uso do
ácido glicólico que é muito comum também
mas intensificam as preocupações com o
ácido glioxílico
Então essa história clínica da paciente
que eu comentei de 26 anos que sofreu a
insuficiência renal de várias formas né
ela teve várias lesões repetidas no rim
em correlação com o tratamento capilar
revela a seriedade desse risco a saúde
associada a esses produtos então se você
usa esse tipo de produto ou conhece
alguém que usa peça para olhar a bula do
produto para ver se tem esse ácido glico
exílio é importante vocês ficarem
atentos a
isso então a paciente que eu comentei
ela experimentou sintomas sistêmicos
como ardor no couro cabeludo náusea
vômito febre dor nas costas o altos
níveis de creatinina plasmática que é
principal aí marcador no sangue de
insuficiência renal
durante cada episódio que ela teve
confirmou que ela teve danos renais
então estudos complementares em
camundongos mostraram acréscimos
significativos de creatinina plasmática
após a exposição ao ácido glioxílico
desculpa não glioxílico é o glioxílico
reafirmando o seu potencial nefrotóxico
Tudo bem então o próximo artigo antes da
gente responder as dúvidas é sobre
probióticos né é uma metanálise
metanálise quando gente pega vários
estudos e junta analisando eles em
conjunto Ok geralmente você pega um uma
ferramenta estatística e junta faz
informações de vários artigos geralmente
artigos de boa qualidade artigos que
geralmente são eh prospectivos E
randomizados então nessa meta análise os
probióticos foram considerados mais
eficazes do que a pílula de farinha o
Placebo na redução dos sintomas de
depressão em adultos que têm transtorno
depressivo maior Então já tinha lido a
há anos atrás sobre o uso de probióticos
para doenças psiquiátricas e
neurológicas Mas a gente não tinha tido
aí uma metanálise sobre isso esse é o
primeiro estudo de metanálise que eu
saiba sobre essa questão dos probióticos
para tratamento de depressão então que
que foi estudado efeitos dos probióticos
em comparação doos antidepressivos para
adultos com depressão compararam
probiótico com antidepressivo e o
principal resultado foram os sintomas de
depressão medidos através de vários
questionários validad dados então foi um
total de 13.000 participantes com idades
entre 23 e 74 anos que apresentavam
transtorno depressivo maior Foi
realizada uma metanálise em rede de 42
estudos então uma metanálise
considerável aí são 42 estudos que foram
unificados todos eles eram randomizados
e era todos ensaios clínicos Então os
ensaios foram realizados na Ásia 17 na
América foram 13 na Europa mais
três e Estudos multinacionais com várias
Nações envolvidas foram nove ensaios
Então os probióticos que foram incluídos
foram as espécies lactobacilos bifido
bacterium e bacilos usado como terapia
complementar aos antidepressivos foram
comparados ao uso de placer que pilo de
farinha os seguintes tipos de
antidepressivos foram investigados que
inibidores seletivos de recaptação de
serotonina que é o mais comum hoje em
dia que é a classe A classe do prosac né
da Fluoxetina da cer Ina a maioria dos
antidepressivos Faz parte dessa classe
dos inibidores seletivos de recaptação
de serotonina são os mais comuns mais
famosos também foram analisados
inibidores da recaptação de serotonina
noradrenalina os antigos antidepressivos
tricíclicos como é o caso da
imipramina da Quem mais tem mais um que
é bem conhecido além da mipr Amina é o e
fugiu agora mas enfim são aqueles
antidepressivos mais antigos e a
quetamina né cetamina que é um
anestésico que também é usado como
antidepressivo e a duração do estudo foi
de 6 a 24 semanas e quais foram os
resultados em comparação com o Placebo
os probióticos reduziram sintomas de
depressão com efeito
moderado então estima-se que os
probióticos sejam mais eficazes do que
vários antidepressivos
eh nessa lista seria o BX PI prazol aar
Ina o Citalopram que é um bastante
famoso também o Citalopram e o
escitalopran AD duloxetina também
bastante conhecida desvenlafaxina também
muito conhecido cetamina o quetamina a
vilazodona e a cortix
cetina né então bem interessante quer
dizer nesse estudo os probióticos foram
mais eficazes do que vários
antidepressivos famosos aí né e não
foram piores do que os outros tá então
foi pelo menos igual ou
melhor então entre todas as intervenções
o e talopram e os probióticos foram os
mais eficazes quer dizer se fosse juntar
duas coisas aí no meio do bolo foi esse
talopram e o
probiótico eu fiquei bem surpreso com
esse resultado esse desse estudo
aí então as eficácias comparativas de
probióticos e antidepressivos foram
estimados com base nos resultados de
estudos separados o que pode introduzir
vieses né vies é o que que é é um tipo
de situação que você sem querer você
coloca uma variável no meio que Acaba
atrapalhando O resultado é tipo uma uma
indução de resultado isso que é o viés
uma indução de resultado até que os
probióticos e os antidepressivos sejam
testados diretamente em comparações
diretas não está claro se os probióticos
são realmente superiores como esse
estudo sugeriu aos antidepressivos então
apenas um estudo investigou a eficácia
doos probióticos como tratamento
independente enquanto os outros
investigaram os probióticos como
tratamento complementar à terapia
antidepressiva que o mais comum era os
inibidores de captação de serotonina
como eu falei então como tratamento
independente os probióticos foram tão
eficazes quanto os antidepressivos de
primeira linha por exemplo esse talopram
e novas terapias
antidepressivas que é no caso aqu
quetamina cetamina que é uma coisa mais
nova mais
recente Bem pessoal vamos responder as
dúvidas de vocês
agora deixa só abr aqui o
arquivo
ah perguntas da Live vamos lá deixa eu
dividir a tela com vocês também jogar
para cá aqui para ficar mais fácil
Ah pera
aí um monte de janela aberta aqui temos
20 perguntas hoje deixa eu começar a
dividir a minha tela com
vocês
hum pera
aí compartilhar aqui mas eu vou aumentar
o tamanho também
da fica mais fácil vocês lerem pergunta
da Marta Pérez Ach Deixa eu tirar eu da
tela
deixa Pera aí que eu fiz bobagem aqui
estão me ouvindo né bem Vamos lá eh
Marta Perez Dr Alan como orienta o uso
dos óleos essenciais do Líbano e da
mirra para ajudar na otimização do
hipotálamo como o dor cita em vídeo
recente eu tenho um vídeo mais antigo
que mostra sobre os óleos essenciais
procura no canal você vai ver que tem
uns três ou quatro vídeos sobre óleos
essenciais é uns vídeos que eu gravei
uns três anos atrás
tá agora basicamente você usa o ele nos
eh como é que se diz difusores eu ten um
difusor aqui na sala da do terra né Não
dá para mostrar acho pelo ângulo aqui
vai ficar ruim de mostrar para vocês mas
basicamente você coloca nos eh difusores
tá e alguns óleos dá para ingerir o óleo
de oliva no Dudo terra por exemplo dá
para injerir você pode pôr duas gotinhas
um meio copo d'água e tomar agora o óleo
de mirra não lembro se o da o do doterra
dá para ingerir tem que dar uma checada
tá então geralmente você usa difusor Ou
pode usar também alguns pode ingerir
alguns colocam em cápsulas né Tem um
pessoal que vende umas cápsulas que você
abre a cápsula e põe as gotinhas na
cápsula engole existe também de você
passar na pele você pega o óleo
essencial duas gotinhas mistura com óleo
de coco né fracionado ou óleo de amendo
tem uns óleos aí que você pode usar e
passar na pele também das temporas tá
então tem esses três modos básicos de
usar depois você assiste os vídeos que
eu falo sobre isso no
canal Pedro Luiz Como deve ser a relação
entre pth e vitamina D eh então eh isso
aí vai depender do Objetivo tá em
condições normais de saúde o ideal que
pth fique por volta de 20 a 25 e a
vitamina D Entre 50 e 70 só que nem
sempre quando você eh sobe a vitamina D
o PT pth cai junto tá Existe sim uma
relação entre os dois mas em alguns
casos você não vê essa queda do pth
quando você aumenta a vitamina D no
sangue tá então é em modo geral é isso
tá manter entre 20 e 25 pth vitamina D
Entre 50 e 70 agora quando você faz o
protocolo da vitamina D como
imunossupressor quando você usa doses
bem altas de vitamina D 50.000 100.000
200.000 por dia e tem que fazer aquela
dieta especial de não comer o cálcio aí
você joga o pth para em torno de 12 tá
em torno de 12 que é é você deixar o pth
No Limite inferior tá é basicamente
isso ruel a life extension parou de
fabricar o coliro bright 3 o uso oral da
carnosina Faria algum efeito no
tratamento de
catarata algum efeito sim mas eu acho
que não F um efeito muito intenso não
sabe mas acho que vale a pena tentar é
esse colid carnosina Tá complicado mesmo
eu acho que não tem mais nenhum jeito de
obter ele eh eh esse era a única fonte
que eu conhecia porque aquela famácia de
manipulação
oftalmológica não faz mais aqui em São
Paulo tá o coleiro de carnosina Então
esse eu acho que essa ferramenta ela tá
sendo
eliminada eh não posso assistir a Live
Pois tenho aula no mesmo horário tudo
bem Marila você assistir depois eu vou
deixar então as perguntas tenho alergia
Severa picada de inseto ouvi falar que
se tomarmos vitamina B1 em dose maior
que a recomendado ess será eliminado
pelo nosso corpo também pelos poros isso
exalar o odor para que os insetos
desagradável procede infamação sim
procede Marilda pode tentar fazer isso
sim tá a vitamina B1 é segura ela não é
tóxica tá então você pode tomar dose
alta tipo 100 mg por dia e ver como é
que vai ser o efeito em termos de
afastar os os
mosquitos Maria Helena o doutor tem
todos os arquivos de perguntas que
fazemos no formular armazenados no
YouTube as perguntas ao vivo temos no
chat Que tal compartilhar conosco para
fazer um arquivo
só é isso já foi sugerido antes tá Maria
Helena só que isso isso na prática é
difícil
tá eu não sei se vocês querem
eh Isso é para organizar isso tomar
tempo
o que eu sugiro é que vocês vão
assistindo aos pouquinhos os vídeos
vocês vão lá tá tudo gravado no canal na
área de membros assiste um vídeo de cada
vez e faz anotações eh Se alguém quiser
fazer isso se colocar como eh voluntário
para criar esse arquivo para todo mundo
é uma boa tá porque eu pensei em fazer
isso com inteligência artificial mas eu
não encontrei um jeito simples de fazer
isso não
tá
exames de saliva na minha cidade 500 km
de São Paulo só tem tercerizado Pode
confiar que estar ativa essa saliva não
Aí você faz com lemos o Lemos tá
acostumado com logística né eles têm lá
os procedimentos que eles fazem para
transporte até 48 Horas não é um
problema para eles lá Não não chega a
deteriorar a saliva
não
ã Maria Elana tenho muita sensibilidade
a magnésios posso tomar ele na forma de
lactato Se sim qual seria a dosagem eu
não tenho uma experiência com lactato de
magnésio Não eu nunca
usei porque daí será só
esse você testou todos os outros
magnésios é isso só o magnésio lactato
que não deu diarreia porque você não
deixou claro que sensibilidade seria
diarreia que você tá falando você tentou
magnésio glicina magnésio estonado
Magnésio malato e todos eles deram
diarreia se você tiver ao vivo por favor
esclareça tenho 62 anos pode tomar
vitamina A só na forma retinol por não
converter mais na forma de betacaroteno
não é ao contrário é o betacaroteno que
vira retinol tá tem gente que tem
dificuldade de fazer a conversão em
betacaroteno em retinol é mais seguro
tomar o retinol sim tá o palmitato de
retinol tomar um 5.000 unidades por dia
mas é bom você fazer o exame de sangue
para ver se você tem deficiência antes
de tomar
OK bico de papagaio conselho seu doutor
exercício não posso transpirar libera
estamina
eh bico de papagaio é uma lesão
degenerativa da idade né vai desgastando
o osso tá conselho meu seria fazer sim
exercício e e e também pode tomar o msm
você pode usar o a condroitina
glucosamina pode usar o colágeno
hidrolizado Tipo
dois o silício tudo isso vai ajudar tá
tem vídeos no canal que fala sobre isso
daí
ã parei vitamina K2 é feito de natom
fermentado tenho alergia à soja e libera
histamina olha mas você parou por quê
você teve reação a vitamina K2 ou você
parou só porque você achou que tem naô
do meio a vitamina D Posso tomar só mas
tinha outros benefícios
né é at As perguntas são um pouco mal
formuladas né Maria Helena seria bom que
se a estivesse ao vivo pod Poderia
ajudar melhor né
Eh tem que ver a fonte da K2 eu acho que
não é a única fonte unat eh tem outras
fontes sim
tá e o que fazer não o seu intestino já
produz vitamina K2 Então você se você
Você tem alergia à soja O que você pode
fazer é utilizar outro alimento
fermentado no lugar que vai ajudar a
formar a vitamina K2 e o fígado também
tá o fígado bovino também é rico em
vitamina
K2 ã quais suplementos indicados para se
usar no início de uma crise de depressão
com dificuldade para dormir e falta de
apetite usa l teanina a taurina também l
taurina tá são coisas segura de usar
taurina e teanina glicina também L
glicina esse aminoácidos são muito bons
tá aí tem os fitoterápicos Mas esse eu
não recomendo você usar sem
acompanhamento médico não eu uso muito
Cava Cava e o hipercon que é a erva de
São João mas esses dois são perigoso se
você não tá tendo acompanhamento médico
Ah que mais você pode usar o lítio
orotato né orotato de lítio tem ação
antidepressiva dá para importar dos
Estados Unidos NOB tem ação
antidepressiva azul de metileno tem ação
antidepressiva
também aí você pode fazer lá na integrit
uns 40 MG de azul de metilen tomar por
dia seria as minhas dicas tá tem muita
coisa que não dá para te falar assim
para você tomar por conta porque tem que
ter acompanhamento
médico o próprio ldn o LX mas esse
também tem que ter acompanhamento médico
Maria Helena esse média usado nos grupos
de ldn no Face não o réia é o nacon de
alta dosagem de 50
mg que você pode tomar entre 50 a 300 mg
mas ele é usado nesse nessa dose para
tratamento de
eh vícios né a álcool e drogas eles
dissolvem um comprimido guardam em
geladeira eles vai tomando todos os dias
sim elas vão diluindo para usar na forma
de ldn isso faz os mesmos efeitos mesmos
efeitos do quê do ldn manipulado sim sim
mas eu recomendo que é mais seguro
manipular tá do que você fazer assim tá
porque você pode errar na diluição
aí eu vou responder as dúvidas ao vivo
quando terminar o arquivo aqui tá
pessoal quem tá aí ao vivo acompanhando
Rosa Maria Existe algum trabalho alguma
pesquisa sobre a dança como exercício
que possa auxiliar no tratamento do
Alzheimer tem tem alguns estudos de
músico terapia de dança em si eu não não
sei eu vou checar isso agora porque eu
tenho uma um serviço aqui de
Inteligência Artificial que vê os
artigos
tá vou olhar
aqui já te respondo em tempo real
aqui faz uma pesquisa nos bancos de
dados dos
artigos vamos ver o que que ele vai
responder
aqui
[Música]
então terapia de dança especificamente a
terapia de movimentos de dança mostrou
efeitos positivos indivíduos com doenças
neurodegenerativas neurodegenerativas
como
Alzheimer estudos tem apontado os
benefícios dessa terapia de dança na
função
cognitiva que mais motor Skills é
habilidades motoras Mood que é humor e
qualidade de vida pacientes com
Alzheimer Além disso formas tradicionais
de dança têm sido
exploradas para indivíduos com demência
mostrando significado cultural
benefícios emocionais melhora da empatia
e expressão
criativa intervenções baseadas em tango
mostraram que são eh reproduzíveis
reprodutíveis né E tem eficácia
eh melhorando a qualidade de vida e o
bem-estar em adultos mais mais velhos
com comprometimento cognitivo sugerindo
o potencial de Terapias de dança para
prevenir e de Clínico funcional nessa
população de modo geral a literatura que
existe sobre isso dá suporte né apoia o
uso de terapia de dança como a um uma
abordagem holística para melhorar
ampliar o bem-estar social físico e
psicológico de pessoas com Alzheimer tá
então respondido Aí sim tem estudos
mostrando a eficácia disso
daí Francisco Weber por favor dor você
algum colega do grupo poderia me enviar
um link de garrafa geradora de
hidrogênio que seja confiável hidrogen
Max tá eu eu eu conheci o dono desse
hidrogen Max e ele produz um bastante
equipamento interessante para
hidrogenação tá hidrogen Max Deixa eu
ver se eu consigo achar o site deles
aqui aqui achei o site deles aqui tá eu
vou colocar aqui o
[Música]
link vou colocar o link aqui para
vocês pera aí tá aí tá Anota aí o link
Carlos kman estimado Doutor considerando
que a metilen inbe enzimas óxidos
nítricos sintas em função disso como
garanti dilatação e flexibilidade Vas
sanguíneos é porque é o seguinte é
confuso mesmo tá existe o óxido nítrico
como mediador de dilatação de vasos como
Mensageiro da dilatação existe também o
óxido nítrico como eh como como Radical
Livre
tá então o azul de metileno ele não vai
inir a dilatação dos vasos ele vai
inibir essa versão do óxido nítrico que
é é um Radical Livre tá
bom Por exemplo neutraliza os resultados
do consumo de arginina quanto a produção
e aproveitamento do óxido nítrico não
creio Tá mas sua pergunta é muito boa
tá não creio mas eu vou checar inclusive
para te dar uma resposta mais
completa Enquanto isso vamos pra próxima
pergunta
aqui vamos voltar ao seu assunto Carlos
tá Marilda fórmula para Complexo B
diário seria essa B1 tiamina 50 B2 5 B3
50 B5 50 B6 50 b7 500 mic B9 5 e B12 500
depende Marilda Isso aqui é uma fórmula
que tem umas dones um pouco altas né
Depende da pessoa tá
eh eu usaria a maioria dessas vitaminas
por exemplo e
tiamina uma pessoa normal usaria 10 mg a
B2 também por volta de 10 a B3 por volta
de 30 B5 Depende se for uma pessoa que
não é fatigada eu usaria também uns 20
MG a piridoxina também uns 20 a b7 Ok
pode ser uns 500 molato pode ser 1 MG
B12 vai depender Mas assim vai depender
de caso a caso mas essas doses que você
colocou aí de modo geral São seguras
tá car Carlos Dr Alan poderia falar
sobre os exames de mineralograma e
oligoscan o oligoscan não uso tá eh eu
conheço esse exame mas conheço assim de
terceiros Eu nunca usei é uma empresa se
eu não me engano espanhola que comprou a
tecnologia do Falecido Dr
Victor esqueci o sobrenome dele mas é um
é um cientista brasileiro um físico e um
cara que era considerado genial ele
descobriu um método de você medir
metais no sangue através de um aparelho
que se aplica na palma da mão então ele
não é invasivo Ele desenvolveu a
princípio vários eh substâncias do
sangue não só para minerais e
oligoelementos mas a Empresa Espanhola
que comprou a tecnologia do Vittor lá Dr
Vittor ela adaptou ele só para ver
minerais tá então eu conheço poucos
médicos que tem esse
equipamento e alguns deles têm essa
dúvida se esse equipamento realmente é
confiável ou não tá eh o mineralograma é
mais confiável quando você faz eh na
saliva no sangue e na urina tá do que
você usar o ligos
cã mineralograma parece amplo mostra Liv
de minerais vitaminas metais pesados é
mais mineral e metal pesado tá
e vitamina não entra muito nesse
conceito aqui não e também como está o
stresse
oxidativo não mineral Grame e por si só
não vê estresse oxidativo não tá não sei
que você tá falando de um exame mais
amplo aí mas é assim eu não uso
oligoscan eu tenho um pouco de pé atrás
com ele tá
Alex qual o melhor horário para tomar
azul de metil não tem horário melhor tá
o horário que você achar mais fácil
lembrar azul de metilen em gotas a 1%
deve ser tomado sub lingual não eu não
AC isso aqui não é necessário não tá
isso aqui é uma conversa que tem na
internet mas é desnecessário já li uma
orientação que não se deve experimentar
azul de metilen com enzima q10 em
conjunto por que que não
pode eu não vejo nenhum problema de
suimar os dois juntos não tá vamos
voltar naquela pergunta do azul de
metileno anterior falando sobre essa
questão do óxido
nítrico então nós sabemos que o ócio
nítrico é um importante vaso dilatador
produzido a partir da linha arginina
como ele colocou né na pergunta e é
produzido pela óxido nitric
sintase sim o azul de metileno inbe as
enzimas óxido nítrico sintase e
guanilato ciclase reduzindo a produção
de óxido nítrico e de gmp cíclico isso
poderia antagonizar as vases de
dilatação mediada pelo óxido nítrico
segundo essa fonte que eu tô checando
aqui bem aqui essa fonte que eu tô
checando tá dizendo sim com azul de
metileno pode antagonizar os efeitos do
óxido nítrico essa vase dilatação
mas ele diz que pode ser anulado essa
essa inibição usando o que alimentos
ficos in Nitrato né que é o caso de
espinafre rúcula beterraba praticar
exercícios físicos regularmente manter
um boa
hidratação isso é uma coisa que eu
preciso olhar com mais calma porque eu
nunca tive essa preocupação de usar o
azul de metileno em pessoas que T por
exemplo problemas aí de ateroesclerose
eu mesmo Uso todo dia mas é uma boa
pergunta que você colocou
viu uma boa pergunta que eu preciso
analisar melhor isso mesmo agora ess
essa história de azul de metileno enzima
que 10 eu também não nunca vi a respeito
vou ver isso
agora
[Música]
tá o azul de metileno ela ele atua por
uma via diferente da coq10 na cadeia
respiratório mitocondrial eles são Ambos
antioxidantes não foi encontrado nenhuma
informação nas referências pesquisadas
sobre interações e contraindicações da
suplementação conjunta de azul de
metileno e cois maqu
10 tá então pelas Fontes que eu chequei
aqui não tem esse problema tá se você
quiser indicar Onde você viu esse Essa
questão aí esse problema seria
interessante viu Alex se você tiver ao
vivo
ã homens mulheres de outros estados que
fazem posição hormonal contigo e fazem
consultoria online como eles fazem com
as receitas eu não faço mais consultoria
online tá fiz isso anos atrás eh quando
ainda não tinha
regulamentação do CRM para consulta
online então criei a consultoria para
passar por cima desse problema mas já
Desde da época da do começo da pandemia
desde
2020 as consultas online foram liberadas
então não tem mais esse problema tá
então não tem nenhum problema de pessoas
de outros estad fazerem reposição
hormonal que as receitas são aceitas no
Brasil inteiro tá então isso não é um
problema mais já tem bastante tempo pelo
menos uns quase 4 anos que esse problema
já não existe mais Antônio Renato a
beberina deve ser ingerida longe das
refeições ou próximo Quantas doses por
dia geralmente é 500 mg duas vezes ao
dia ou três vezes ao dia tá
eh não tem nenhum problema em relação à
alimentação não você pode tomar de jejum
ou depois de uma alimentação mas o mais
recomendado se puder tomar depois de uma
alimentação bem vamos paraas perguntas
ao
vivo esse protocolo que o Eliseu tá
comentando aqui os olhos de águia é um
de exercícios oculares Até onde eu
sei o que causa tupimento das veias você
deve estar falando das artérias né
Fernanda as artérias que levam que levam
o sangue oxigenado do coração pro resto
do corpo
né Eh o aterosclerose é provocada pelo
envelhecimento tá pela oxidação do
LDL o colesterol por exposição a metais
pesados por várias substâncias que tem
efeito oxidativo né são os radicais
livres
eh poluentes ambientais cigarro eh
radiação ultravioleta Tem várias coisas
que podem causar tupimento das
artérias Qual é a relação das doenças
autoimunes com parasitas então tem gente
que acha que os parasitas podem aumentar
o risco de doenças autoimunes e tem uma
outra turma que acha que os parasitas
que eram muito mais comuns antigamente
pelo menos os elos né que são aqueles
paritas grandes grandes multicelulares
eles protegiam a gente das doenças
autoimunes então tem essas duas visões
tá existe gente que estudiosa desse
assunto que diz que na época que tinha
muito mais lombriga nas crianças tinha
muito menos alergia e doença autoimune
então Esso é um assunto
bastante polêmico né porque tem muita
gente que acha que todos os problemas do
mundo aí é por causa de parasita Tem um
pessoal que exagera nessa questão
aí é mas os outros suplementos você deve
estar falando eliz deve ser aqueles
ômega-3 licopeno
astaxantina esse tipo de coisa que a
gente passa também no consultório mas
que é diferente ele não vai impedir a
glicação como é o caso da
carnosina o efeito Smart drugs é aquele
que o Tor L falou no vídeo é sim mas é
eles são viciantes geralmente tá isso
ele não falou muito no vídeo mas eles
geralmente são viciantes são parecidos
com
cocaína não você pode até ficar sem
dormir porque vários deles não te D O O
estímulo estimulante estímulo
estimulante é ótimo né Você vai ficar
estimulado demais vai ficar como se ess
tomado 10 l de café e fica sem dormir tá
então tem gente que consegue realmente
virar a noite estudando mas eu não
recomendo o uso contínuo nem o Rair
Ribeiro ele Recomendo o uso contínuo
dessa Smart drugs não tá só para usar
por máximo um mês aí
tá aumenta a capacidade intelectual mas
tem os seus preços tá então para um cara
que tá num final de um uma tese
doutorado alguém que tá fazendo o
concurso final aí do período do estudo
de concurso um mês de uso no máximo aí
não não passar disso
tá sim pode ser usado em conjunto com
suplementos neotrópicos não isso eu já
respondi não pode ser usado
continuamente é
perigoso mais perguntas
pessoal
muito inteligente essa pergunta aqui do
eu acho que foi o Carlos ketman né em
relação a azul de
metileno Deixa eu voltar
lá isso essa daqui
ó bem eu tomo as duas coisas tá eu tomo
uma fórmula que dá suporte a óxido
nítrico eu uso Azul metileno Tá mas eu
nunca tive essa preocupação direta de
que o de metileno poderia
eh neutralizar o efeito da argelina mas
ISS a sua preocupação é real viu Carlos
pelas Fontes que eu Consultei aqui são é
real mesmo então talvez seja uma boa
ideia consumir horários Diferentes né US
de metileno por exemplo de manhã e
argenina à noite poderia
tá minimizando esse problema
aí não ele recomendou 30 dias se você
for assistiu aquele vídeo de novo que
você por mais de 30 dias não usar ele
fala rapidamente lá e não dá explicação
Mas é por causa que eles são viciantes
Eliseu a aí depois a pessoa não consegue
tirar mais o a medicação e pode ter
problema de ansiedade nervosismo Você
viu que ele comentou lá que a esposa
quase pediu as contas que falou que se
ele continuasse tomando ela pedia
divórcio porque ele deve ter ficado
irritadiço com certeza né não foi à toa
que ela falou aquilo
lá
mais alguma pergunta
pessoal aqui depois de usar Smart drugs
por apenas um mês e parar quantos meses
depois eu posso voltar a tomar novamente
eu sugeriria uns se meses tá para dar um
tempo seu corpo não ficar
dependente
e obrigado viu Carlos por ter me chamado
atenção para esse assunto porque quando
eu estudei o azul de
metileno isso não ficou tão Evidente na
nos meus estudos tá agora eu vou ficar
mais atento com essa relação do do eu
acho que na prática não deve dar tanto
problema não viu Carlos porque o azul de
mentil tem tanta ação boa para organismo
né mas quando se trata de reposição de
de substância que aumenta o óxido
nítrico eu acho que tem que ter essa
preocupação sim como você
colocou Está vigília é o nome comercial
da budan fila tá tem outros outros SM
drugs lá mas eles não vão te vender sem
receita tá e Geralmente as receitas são
controladas bem pessoal acho que tá bom
já né são quase 45 minutos de
vídeo bem nós no vemos semana que vem
Obrigado pela sua participação Lembrando
que todos os vídeos ficam gravados no
canal tá Se alguém quiser começar a
fazer isso aos pouquinhos começar a
assistir os vídeos mais antigos e
começar a fazer um documento catalogando
as perguntas e respostas porque eu tenho
os arquivos
das perguntas Tá mas eu não tenho das
respostas as respostas foram respondidas
por áudio nos vídeos então para fazer
isso
eh é trabalhoso fazer isso né E
realmente tem que ter uma motivação
forte para fazer isso daí Se alguém
quiser fazer eu acho uma boa um abraço
para vocês até a próxima semana próximo
vídeo l